signori siamo su green ciao come dice il
titolo in hell sarebbe inferno verde
così per far capire che capisco
l'inglese inferno verde rega è un
survival salva euro tipo the forest non
so spiegarvi meglio tipo the forest è
fighissimo perché è uscito ed esploso
tipo di rarissimo quindi spero sia fatto
bene perché se ci giocano in così tanti
sarà mica una cagata speriamo di no led
tv premuti per usare voti tolti abele
sia il modulo schiacciare io peccato
avevo insultarla fortissima va bene ok
va bene a parte tirare pugni a vuoto io
vado avanti
vediamo se riesco a trovare delle robe
recenti siamo qui per cercare il
villaggio degli a bannu vaca non so cosa
siano però questo è l'accampamento
chiama mia a si chiama mia dove prendere
ma che figata bellissime fatto benissimo
trova un utensile per tagliare gli
alberi va bene machete
penso vada bene trova legna da ardere ok
ma ci sono due addirittura due machete
che figata possono abbattere qualsiasi
ma che figata è fatto benissimo
il wig 800 ore per fare un [ __ ] fuoco
usa gli utensili per creare un tizzone
come si usano gli utenti diagnosi che
diagnosi taccuino come sono che ne so io
hai un accendino ai quali va a cagare
non avevo capito dove fosse lì che gioca
con le barbie e di melo subito va bene
facendo io faccio io usa gli utenti
perché è un tizzone azione basta trapano
a mano va bene mi sono un bastone e un
bastone corto per accendere il fuoco da
solo va bene ma che fatica perché le
donne si dimenticano il il come il
accendino li mortacci de nino eccolo qua
bastone corto il trapano a mano ce
l'abbiamo
gli utensili processo vi chiedo come
trovano cosa di asciutto come un nido
d'uccello fibra
ok ma questo gioco bear grylls simulator
ma spiegami foglia secca o teoria questa
dovrebbe fungere da combustibile in
teoria io che vedo un sacco cazzo si
chiama national geographic
quello lì posso spostare le cose come
vogliono è fighissimo figlia un fenomeno
ci ho messo un'ora per accendere un
fuoco ok se dite se questo gioco deve
diventare ascoltare i problemi delle
donne simulator lisa melo prima che vado
a far niente ha finito a che stavo
guardando alle storie di mauro icardi
andiamo avanti
simpatica la mia ragazza
l'ispezione la tenda tesoro dove sei
cioè sta roba qua prendiamo la pugna
caso nota sono al villaggio calma
incacchia nicola radio con disegni ps
c'è un piccolo regalo per te ti amo mia
ok è questo regalo per me all'orologio
carino proprio cosa di nutriente da
mangiare berg risi insegna datemi un po
di microbi nel nel fiume che mangio
acqua pulita come pulita sembra che ci
ha pisciato un cammello hai bevuto acqua
pulita 20 di transazione va bene
idratazione come sta messa idratazione o
ragazza al suo punto di vista è molto
più figo che the forest cioè l'orologio
dice sta roba è fighissimo
c'è più niente e dolorosa che mi dice
quando ho fame fantastico va adesso non
dovrò più accorgermene da solo che ho
fame me lo dice l'orologio utilissima
sta roba pre vado troppo per inutilmente
da mangiare va bene ho trovato un cocco
dovrebbe essere nutriente problema è che
non so come si aprono i cocchi
let's go veri
che genio e adesso dopo e magna teoria
sì e qualsiasi cosa puoi fare nella vita
tu te lo fa fare nel gioco è fighissimo
ho preso dei carboidrati city costoro
logio ho mangiato e non era abbastanza
nutriente cocco iniziare un altro una
scatola di fagioli fungo sconosciuto vai
proviamo a mangiare i funghi credo che
siano nutrienti no
mangia c'è il culo non sono morto posso
quanto ancora devo mangiare quanto
magnitudo essere umano quanta roba le
banane ma quante lo posso trovare da
mangiare ma fighissimo magna magna e
banale però qualcosa di nutriente non
c'è mai un ora che sto mangiando una
basta se invece di step di auto magna
questo basta uno rai e foglia di palma
barretta proteica questo e nutriente
speriamo ok passata un'ora cerca cibo
nelle e poi c'era una barretta proteica
tua madre morta giorno 32 wow che è
successo arrivò arrivo arrivo è il
successo arriva arriva arrivo arrivo
bastone lungo come il miope e dove vado
dove non prendi michael volevo andare a
casa e volevo solo andare a fare la
spesa all'eurospin ma dove mai portato
questa li mortacci della mia suocera
modalità storia comprendo tutto questo
era il tutorial si scemo come la
tutorial via via via che tutorial via lo
trovai mia moglie perché mia moglie e
mia
così per pagarlo morto prendi ok da cui
non ho voce torcia debole ma chi se ne
frega vai togliti lo schifo vai troviamo
mia moglie che è morte non è morta ma
gli oggetti che ho preso se ne sono
andati a [ __ ] bene che chi sta
urlando sento più sceso in terra
fai da te di ragazzi e tua madre co
demonio morto ieri ma che te urli e tua
madre morta ma che cosa urli stabile
aveva chiamato quanti sé ma che cosa
stai ora ma come siete che cazzata
attacco dei giganti ma via via via via
che ho sete o se te ti stanno so se
condotto persone o sete cosa ai 7 c
bellissimo uno che corre tra indigeni
dietro ho sete non sa mi sa che gli dei
problemi prioritari in questo momento
porca vacca ma che sei
rocky balboa la donna che fastidio
quando sei morto lo so che sono morti
sono di gente che urla mi dà fastidio
sono morto molto prima di quanto pensi
ragazzi la gente più urla più forte ho
capito
quell'animale li fa male se lo mi tocca
non lo so ma non lo tocchiamo perché nel
dubbio permesso baratto loro prendo
subito tanto magna subito questi tanto
questo ci sa fare
qui si mangia volo il baratto l'intero
non ho la roba dentro un barattolo
mangia il barattolo coltello ho
finalmente trovato un'arma ci ho messo
un anno e mezzo per trovare un'arma però
vabbè lo snack magnate puro cose neanche
tanto ci hai sempre fatto che ore sono
non lo so però fame che ore sono ho fame
questi lippi non si sa mai
anzi premio subito che stai morendo non
so per quale motivo
che bello sto forno a microonde se con
un forno a microonde trasformato in
giradischi
ok va bene avanti momento di caccia rega
è molto vicino in amicizia del lancio e
pam e te lo regalo e per the work a
vacca che finisse verdi che male se vi
prende di fa malissimo aiuto con aveva
una freccia l'ho visto conosco cava mi
sono permesso di essere così poco
amichevole perché loro lo sono stati con
me l'altra volta non è perché sono
cattivo tanto tipo non mi ha seguito si
è cagato
non è che è morto aree quello c'è un
coltello impiantato nel nella gamba ma
continua va bene è un coltello ma fa
niente
ce l'hai sull'orologio shazam perché non
mi sta vedendo fermi e zitti zitti non
credo mi abbia sta correndo a non mi ha
visto mi ha visto porca vacca spera di
trovare il coltello meloni dai il
coltello e non l'arco posso picchiarti
notato non mi prendi non c'e lavoro di
mezzo a work of che pugno e schiaffo
arco demonio
minchia mi chiamavano rocky balboa
prendi l'arco per gli arco ciò le frecce
mamma mia che fenomeno lavora cosa vuol
dire ma che schifo che sta facendo ma
che schifo
cosa fa ma poiché mag
perché prova cucinare visto che ho fame
cucinano della carne umana cruda no sto
morendo ma vabbè vorrei trovare un era
pieno di animali prima era pieno c'era
animali ovunque non ce n'e manco più
mezzo come adesso dice all arco porca
vacca
va beh direi che posso fare un
accampamento qui che è pieno di animali
e sono vicino anche un torrente quindi
posso bere accampamento let's go ei
ragazzi fatemi sapere se volete altri
episodi di green
se devi sapere se volete la seconda
parte di the green è il re green nell si
chiama così non mi ricordo più che non
fosse trovare o mia moglie però so fare
dei bei fuochi cena vero tasto uccidere
stirare i pugni spero che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi
lasciate un commento mi piace anche ai
600 mila donne scrizione sapersi
rischiate noi ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]